okay
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
i had to set that one lightly because it
is scalding hot again but that's a good
thing no we didn't get it
of uh it'll be at the proper room
temperature
hotter than room temperature it won't
everything won't taste like rubber for a
month in about
three minutes time i kind of want it hot
enough to where you spill it on your lap
and then shriek and again um so this by
the way yeah the mug i think it's
wonderful and then
yeah yeah pretty much it's a wonder it's
wonderful size but uh the thing is
unless you fill it since it can fit a
whole beer it could fit a whole point
it doesn't stay hot for very long to
pre-heat the people out there wonderful
handheld mug uh you can join mugler to
see how you support the show yeah but
some people are like well it's like
you're putting a shot of espresso in a
cold mug
what are you expecting what do you
expect
understand the laws of thermodynamics
greta
we're going to be talking about
that today but uh before we get to look
i want you to know we're going to be
talking about australia uh in today's
show there's some breaking news coming
out of australia yeah i know a lot of
americans say well come on who cares now
i understand that however it is a
cautionary tale it's very important for
you to understand what's going on in
australia so you can understand
the slow erosions of your freedom and
australia's gone a little further but
you know where i was raised in canada
they've taken extreme measures too so
i've kept my eye on it
you know people think just things like
curfews well that's pretty bad too
it goes way further than that and if you
look at australia you need to understand
where it started and it goes back to the
90s and it's the frog and the boiling
water which are becoming gay so
these are facts i don't know these are
facts these are facts so we'll be
talking about australia and to our
australian viewers we have a lot we are
sorry our hearts are with us love you
aussies but before that gerald a how are
you i
no they pronounce their s's properly and
uh quarter black garrett you're fired
good morning good morning court court
still quarterbacks still in there well
you know unlike unlike the unelected
governor of new york i don't think that
you people are stupid well thank you oh
i appreciate it i mean i'm pretty stupid
but it's okay well thank you that's an
olive branch i just wouldn't speak as a
with a broad generalization
as the unelected governor of new york
has regarding yes black citizens of her
state that's true uh of course dave
landau is here and you are ahoy good
yeah i'm alive well you have a big show
coming up this friday carnegie music
hall in homestead pennsylvania we have
the link in the description where you
can buy tickets they're uh they're going
fast there aren't many left so i would
recommend
probably today we will be plugging this
tomorrow buy it because i help a brother
out yeah yeah and it's a good haul where
you don't you know these people are
letting you go there and
have control over your own body not
forcing you to test oh well that's nice
yeah you'd get to choose you get to
choose
uh speaking of choosing some interesting
creative choices made by uh
the uh
the non-leader in late night uh stephen
colbert
and i look it's a very lazy attack for
people just say that something isn't
funny okay because i understand that
comedy is subjective
but i think we've crossed the line here
no i don't mean a line of propriety i
just mean it's it's it really i think
that we can objectively put this in the
categorically unfunny you guys comment
below if you watch this
sketch what will we call it dave
um abomination
you know i really didn't see much of it
i only saw a second so i'm gonna have to
decide okay it's uh it seems like
propaganda for the vaccine companies
really i don't know maybe
listen stephen colbert's actually uh he
i have this from sources of pi he has uh
a vested interest in madonna as a matter
of fact stephen colbert owns
all of moderna he owns the madonna and
he's making it he's making the fraud
uh he's going to be in the show tomorrow
by the way
in studio yeah help
so we're going to have to have a talk as
a gay frog yes i hope so
i'm doing this to make a point yeah this
is to draw attention to the reality uh
this is sickening to me as well that's
why i dressed up like a gay frog and
wore the undergarments that's a great
video to hop into my imagination
[Laughter]
if you want to see
paradise simply look around and you will
you will i'm a human all right
i love alex you're going to have a heart
that's true how many stints has he had
uh today
no no i take my oregano oil so stephen
colbert
i had this filter
i have this carbon block filter takes
all the heart attack juice out of it
takes a heart attack juice out
i'm kind of [ __ ] you can get that
it doesn't though you can get your water
from chemtrails ladies and gentlemen i
will get my water from
from god from mother nature this is a
lean mean fat reducing grilling machine
yes george foreman's not with it anymore
i am it takes the gay out of your stakes
i also have uh nine sons named alex so
it was appropriate
not you
[Laughter]
it's like multiplicity
you just get dumber
okay so stephen colbert did the sketch
last night uh i don't know look i will
call this a sketch but i just want you
to see it in all of its splendor let's
roll it the vaccine
[Music]
let's see what they did there
[Music]
uh stephen yeah oh my god
[Music]
um
stephen i
i really don't know if i can like dip
we'll talk about it after
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
stephen is yeah okay well we'll talk
about after this eclipse almost done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice dancing
let's see
dave hold on we got to just finish that
i want everyone to see it in this
context
otherwise they'll say that we you know
we edit it out of context
oh they switched tequila to vaccine oh
[Applause]
yeah this is not a big studio
we don't have the cbs budget oh what'd
you eat oh
all right that's not important
okay oh yeah yeah that's just
get him a carbon block filter man oh i'm
sorry
i just so deed on all those needles and
uh your thoughts on the uh
your thoughts on the sketch what a
junkie sees when he scores heroin
just
dancing needles you know
everyone else really yeah it comes
we're going to ride the horse hopefully
yeah
the first time on the left looked a
little objectively objectively uh well i
don't think they're in bed with any
any sort of health company no
vaccine
um objectively uh wow
well i don't want to say it on youtube
okay but there should be ways that he is
replaced
um
there's adam drive down uh drive down
midtown on a convertible
sam jackson wouldn't say yes to that
nicholas cage would give that i think
you're right i don't think he's in bed
with a vaccine company a matter of fact
well as a matter of fact breaking news
i've found out that he has relinquished
his stake in madrid they have paid him
billions to in fact not do any more
sketches this has been a double cross a
double cross alex
that would make sense that would make
sense
it's just so look you guys come out
and let me know i mean i just that's
what pee herman dance yeah
i mean what considering how funny he was
on comedy central and i think he was
very funny i do yeah yesterday we talked
about how john oliver is funny even
though i disagree with him yes i i mean
just that is uh okay who's his wife is
his base 85 like who's watching yeah his
demo is it's about it used to be fox
news it's really old oh wow you need to
know this it's abc nbc cbs their their
demographic is is it's all very old
right now they're reviewing it all make
sense yeah their viewers are dying in
record numbers well their viewers
probably do need the giant vaccines they
do i don't care if they're three if uh
halloween a kid shows up to my house
dressed as a vaccine i'm going to kick
him off my horse just pop him one right
now i'm going to egg him yeah oh yeah
it's a house i'll throw a candy at your
kid's soft spot
i'm going to give him a peg a bag of poo
and light i mean that's it
why
yeah
don't you feel like you've lost like a
piece of you over the years yes yes i do
ah
okay
writers were like this and they were
like yes
yeah good to go what are you gonna do
are you gonna tell the uh what's the
what's the term you're gonna tell the
lesbian of color with ricketts that her
material isn't good enough you want to
have hr
in there faster than a duck on a june
bug for crying out what are you gonna do
he's like this is great okay we'll just
we'll replace tequila with vaccine
thank you skylar it's like the 1950s
shows that were brought to you by lucky
strike yeah the colgate comedy
now it's just vaccines the whole show
it's the pfizer comedy hour yeah it's
fun johnson and johnson comedy hour yeah
there you go no need to refrigerate just
stick it in your rear it's moderna time
yes
okay uh so here's another thing really
quickly before we get to australia and
uh and general milly by the way that
happened yesterday while we were live on
air i didn't know it was uh some things
that definitely need to be uh hit on uh
namely general milly nancy pelosi
yesterday though slipped and
accidentally said the quiet part out
loud what we've all been thinking hear
it straight from the horses uh
here straight from the speaker's mouth
keep government open we intend we have
to do those imminently uh
more intimately even
to address the full
obama agenda of building back better i i
used to say where's your stephen tyler
scarf if i could make an arrangement
where
um
i had a i had a
stand in a front man
or front woman and and they had an
earpiece in and i was just in my
basement in my sweats
looking through the
stuff and then i could sort of deliver
the lines but somebody else was
uh doing all the talking and ceremony i
i'd be fine with that now look i don't
think you need to be a serial killer
with red yarn in your basement yeah to
see that
stephen colbert
vaccine sketch nancy pelosi talking
about barack obama of course has been on
cold bear they've all had drinks
together
they're all getting together at cocktail
hour this is not about just left versus
right i'm a conservative i don't run
from that this is truly about the elites
in power versus you no more cocktails
none whatsoever by the way i think nancy
pelosi now speaks in unintelligible
words and then eventually she'll say
something that you're like oh yes now i
have to go back and try to piece that
into what you just said did you actually
say
what what it's during the it's her
satanic prayer language yeah yeah i
don't know i don't i don't quite
i just noticed her wearing that nice
skin tight pink dress and i thought wow
i didn't know you could get hotter
it's a pantsuit boosty is that what that
is yes it's painted
uh by the way we here at must be made in
heaven yes
uh let's okay let's let's just move on
sorry i mean no that's okay here's the
next one greta steunberg did this
yesterday at uh some youth climate
summit to keep let's keep this in
context she is 18.
i know she looks 12. officially but she
is 18.
oh i'm sorry it was i was thinking it
can't fill that up anymore
you know what look i don't want to tell
him i don't want to i don't want to be
in control of his eating habits he's not
his choice no that was just the mention
of god
stephen
by the way still the winner of the
stephen merchant lookalike foundation uh
three years running really yeah that's
good that's yeah he's a shoe-in she's a
girl a lady of many talents here she is
talking
uh like a rap disc just crapping on
everyone for not doing enough for the
environment including biden including
aoc if you read between the lines
and also this is very lazy
[Applause]
there is no planet b
there is no planet blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
this is what happens when you're
homeschooled and procrastinated talk
about some expensive politically correct
green act of bunny hugging or blah blah
blah oh honey hugging see what's
happening back better blah blah blah
green economy blah blah blah
net zero by 2050 blah blah blah net zero
blah blah blah climate neutral blah blah
blah this is all we're here you're
eighteen
leaders
words
words that sound great
not yours no that has led to no action
our hopes and dreams drown in their
empty words and promises
what do we want
blah blah when do we want it
for you to go away forever you have
overstayed your welcome wow she's the
worst remember when youtube's policy was
you couldn't criticize her because she
wasn't 18.
yeah not anymore not anymore
thank god she is now right there you go
it's like the olsen twins countdown
clock only to make sure that we turn off
the television yes oh gross so we here
of course at louder with crowder we uh
we really that being said we do care
about the environment and we're touched
by the overall sentiment uh from greta's
inspiring words um so we have our
environmental uh correspondent of course
last week was the all the late night
hosts came together to do their uh to do
their green uh their climate day it was
helpful climate week yeah we didn't
dancing needles no i think it did a lot
well look but we didn't we didn't get
the the the memo so we assumed we lost
the mail so we decided of course to take
uh take action here and we have our
environment correspondent uh oh oh okay
it's thomas finnegan to uh help show us
how to fight against climate change
[Music]
hello mr finnegan okay you are there so
today you're going to teach us how do
you know
climate change is a problem
and the late night hosts are combining
their forces this week to combat that
correct because climate change is not a
problem for some time in the future
it's right now
so i set up this experiment so that we
could measure
exactly what it is that we're putting
into the atmosphere oh well that's good
science gentlemen
start your engines
huh
[Music]
i don't think that's very helpful thomas
uh
regardless of the if you have a
refractometer science
see the
emissions
thomas
[Music]
well we'll we'll see where this is going
yeah we'll check back in thomas i don't
have high hopes uh by the way uh hey you
can uh what are we telling people
subscribe to the podcast today yeah yeah
you can subscribe to the podcast on the
uh or is it a podcast am i talking about
uh instagram there's so many things up
there there's so many things with your
podcast
apple store
store you can get this uh and the best
way to tune in hit the notification bell
okay
because subscriptions don't really mean
anything on youtube it's a live show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we don't want to be your only show but
we do it live and if you're in my club
we take your chats i have great news by
the way not yet mm-hmm ranger panties
will be making a yes back to the merch
yeah we sold out because of the coven
shortage uh all the supplies right now
really hard to get uh steel
lumber and ranger panties who knew that
i love the list that in toilet paper you
know steel and lumber involved in the
range
coming soon
yeah to crowder shop yeah walker texas
yeah he's five foot two that uh that
chuck norris is he really yeah very nice
guy he's shorter than me
yes
so general
general do you promise
terrible man told me to always keep my
promises if i want to keep my friends so
i don't want to speak out of turn no
we'll measure you against the doorway
after we'll do it yeah okay all right
october 1st you guys can hit the link in
the description
so general milly testified for congress
yesterday and this is there are a couple
things that we need to touch on you guys
all know about the fact that he called
and warned china about donald trump yeah
however this is something that uh as i
was watching it after we were done with
the show
i think some people may have missed
uh and uh we were talking before this
about how it's treasonous
and having watched this now um i would
actually i would actually you know look
i'm not beyond changing my opinions it's
absolutely treason yeah it's absolutely
treasonous
so uh here he is talking about his job
under donald trump and why he called
the china
these military-to-military
communications at the highest level are
critical to the security of the united
states in order to deconflict military
actions manage crisis and present
prevent war between great powers that
are armed with the world's most
deadliest weapons
the specific purpose of the october and
january is smiling regenerate or were
generated by concerning intelligence
which caused us to believe the chinese
were worried about an attack on them by
the united states
i know i am certain
that president trump did not intend to
attack the chinese that's pivotal and it
is my directed responsibility
and it was my directed responsibility by
the secretary to convey that intent to
the chinese
my task at that time was to de-escalate
no
let's be really clear about this your
task is not to de-escalate your task is
to serve at the pleasure of the
president notably if you are in the
military or occupying any military role
the commander-in-chief this is a term
that's thrown around very often so a lot
of people don't understand it's not
really a term that applies to civilians
it applies to the military the president
of the united states has the final say
in the world's most powerful military
fighting force the most powerful
military fighting force that's ever
existed bar none you may not like it but
it's absolutely the truth your job is to
serve the commander-in-chief now what's
pivotal there is that he said i knew
that donald trump wasn't going to attack
the chinese but uh i was concerned that
they were concerned first off who gives
a rat's ass second do you understand how
this is cutting off the commander in
chief cutting him off at the knees
it's posturing look the commander in
chief has the right to make all final
says have the final word
on any military operations that includes
strategy that includes placement that
includes tactics that includes by the
way posturing what do you think look
especially at this point in time when
china was responsible for the pandemic
that has been released upon the world
and you can bring up this overlay a lot
of you have forgotten blaming the united
states military keep that in mind the
chinese government officially blaming
the united states military for the
spread of kovid it's important to
posture keep china on their toes donald
trump can't do that if hey you know he
has no intent of using
nukes no intent of waging war but it's a
fake out it's a fake out he's got to be
able to faint and what do you think
happens if the general undercuts them
what do you think the cold war is a
perfect example all that was was
posturing we have nukes they have nukes
what's going to happen i don't know
maybe you should play ball
that's what needs to happen with china
when they are in fact the enemy of the
world as it relates to freedom and of
course even your freedoms the freedoms
of people in australia because of a
virus that they lied about absolutely
and i thought the whole justification
for this was to avoid him trying to go
to some kind of like nuclear war or
something like that with china after
january 6. i'm like oh well that makes
sense and then i see this i'm like
you just undercut yourself by the way he
called china in uh october oh really
yeah so it had nothing to do with
january 6. he made it in the election he
called china yes
how do you call china well collect no i
mean like collect stick it to them any
which way you can you're like hey china
like who's on the other end of the phone
i'm being serious
either way it's in this situation yeah
you'd probably call the i don't know if
it's the prime minister the ambassador i
think it's overlay b if you cause i'm
wondering if i was just being siri like
do you remember this the cdc was caught
on the spot when did patient zero begin
in u.s this is a legend lila jing or
lilin with li jian xiao yeah i don't
remember official media again
how many people are infected what are
the names of the hospitals it might be
u.s army who brought the epidemic to
wuhan if that is not a reason to posture
war
then you're saying there's no reason to
ever actually admonish have sanctions
punish another nation no matter how
irreparable the damage it is not your
job to de-escalate general milly it is
your job to serve under the
commander-in-chief but we get it yeah
you had a book deal absolutely and i
think people forget this part too one of
the reasons that we posture with china
is so that they don't just go and take
taiwan what they have wanted to do
forever i know we want to keep going
there as much as possible no no we don't
we want to stay out of there right no
taiwan right yeah i don't want i don't
want that to happen they have to be able
to defend themselves it's the same thing
that russia was trying to do they were
trying to spread throughout the country
basically throughout the world and just
kind of put communism in every country
they could and we had to posture and it
worked yeah it helped it absolutely
helped in taiwan as important taiwan as
an ally and of course they look this is
anyway we can get into all the
geopolitics which is a little bit it's a
little bit redundant people like
geopolitics to sound smarter i just did
it i hope you guys didn't catch it
comment below international politics
well you're essentially he's supposed to
be the crazy guy that they're afraid of
right right
and
effectively
he just came out like no guys i'm a real
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly what happened to
all of our generals like every time we
have a general in a movie they're always
like nukem blow it up nuke him yeah this
guy's like oh we're sorry we want to
make sure that we're not going to know
there's no fighting in the world donald
trump loves to talk yes
there is no way he would nuke a country
or wage war without warning them so this
was not act look for people who don't
like donald trump do you think this was
accidental hey are you planning on
starting war i don't know
i have no idea no i would never i would
never
send over drones or drop biochemical
weapons at our favorite ally who
released the wuhan virus oh no
well yeah who are you more afraid of the
person you think's a little bit crazy
or the one that you know you can just
walk all over exactly
and that's a look hey if anything that
tells us the president tells us that he
knows the original argument him and
pelosi was that the president was
unstable you just said i knew he wasn't
going to do it i just wanted to make
sure that chyna knew and then i told him
if anything would ever happen i would
give them a heads up oh a surprise
military strike a coup if you will uh is
meant to not include a heads up
there's a reason why we make these
things fast yes yes
all right so he also here's something
else too he completely contradicts that
statement yeah when he was asked by um i
don't remember who uh who was here
asking him uh we'll have the clip it'll
come up tom cotton is it tom cotton yeah
uh he was asked about the fact that he
actually said we need some kind of
general milling said we needed some kind
of a maintenance level of troops in
afghanistan okay this was his this was
his advisement to the current former
vice president of the united states and
uh former vice president biden declined
so
this is where we have a direct
apples-to-apples comparison uh look at
what general milley had to say about
this why haven't you resigned
senator
as a senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing it's
a political act if i'm resigning in
protest my job is to provide advice my
statutory responsibilities provide legal
advice or best military advice to the
president and that's my legal
requirement that's what the law is
um the president doesn't have to agree
with that advice he doesn't have to make
those decisions
just because we're generals and it would
be an incredible
act of political defiance for a
commissioned officer to just resign
because my advice is not taken this
country doesn't want generals
figuring out what orders we're going to
accept and do or not that's not our job
okay hold on a second which is it is it
it's not your job to defy and pick which
orders or it's your job to defy
the president of the united states and
de-escalate because he made a judgment
call there that went against the
commander-in-chief and now you made a
direct advisement to the current former
vice president of the united states he
declined and you're saying it's not my
job to determine what he does which is
it pick a lane before we move on to the
bagram air base i want to go to cnn
really quickly uh this is clarissa ward
i assume she's in afghanistan look
that have been established i'll tell you
why this irritates you i'm wearing this
so i don't get a brick thrown at yes
exactly very nice people will say well
what is she supposed to disrespect the
culture let me ask you this how would
you feel if she was going to a to a
donald trump rally and was forced to
wear a maga hat yeah she's wearing that
because she's in a country where they'll
throw acid on the face of little girls
if they try to go to high school yeah
it's like somebody coming to american a
babushka and you throw a yankees hat on
them right they're like i wanted my
baboosh or mets well and by the way
i love how i love how the just read that
miley admits u.s credibility damage
after afghan you think yeah yeah i'm
sorry a little is this something you
just came to like oh
maybe this is going to make us look bad
how about we just be the arrogant
bastards that foreign relation that they
claim we are how about you walk into
afghanistan and they say put this uh i
don't know what their ak's firing into
the air that stray bullet hits some girl
trying to go to a grade school because
she's locked out like the tiger and the
flintstones how about you walk it in
there and they say put this on you think
no i'm american not going to do that you
can't why because as much as you [ __ ]
about american conservatives being
intolerant they don't blow [ __ ] up if
you don't put on a head scarf i'm sorry
uh uh hijab
yeah
yeah that really is true well and we
kind of glossed over this point we
brought it up yesterday but this whole
idea that we were not going to leave any
troops behind that there was no other
plan that this couldn't have been
anything but chaotic according to joe
biden
and he had advisers saying leave people
behind because this is going to get bad
if we don't he's like no no no no we
don't need to leave anybody behind it's
totally fine trust me they can hang on
to the wheel wells of planes they'll be
just fine
yep maybe not hey how much you want to
bet look i'll make this bet right now
comment below and then call me on it if
i'm wrong i'll hang my hat on this how
much you want to bet that this happens
with the border crisis that we find out
two three five months from now that
people advise the former vice president
saying hey listen this is going to be a
crisis here because of your laws the
fact that you haven't completed the wall
the fact that you've welcomed them
you've incentivized people we're going
to have a migrant crisis and this is my
advice on what you should do about it
and he ignored it because the media just
moves on right now no no
you need to hold his feet to the fire
remember that cnn remember that jim
acosta with donald trump he said there
was no way for this to not be chaotic
which of course uh flies in the face of
what he said two months prior saying
there would be no incidents yeah but i
guarantee you this same thing is going
to happen with the border crisis and
what will happen is the media will just
continue rolling on
never being held accountable watch call
me on it will in a bet the fact that the
leader of the free world has to be
explained something so obvious right is
horrifying it really is really it's like
look there's a bunch of illegals coming
here yeah what's what's wrong with that
well
they're going to keep coming and then
you know stuff
like it can't be should i should i tell
them that i'm not going to deport them
yeah is that going to help am i being
punked like you really want me to
explain it's harder to connect one dot
on a denny's placemat
and it is the stuff that biden can't
seem to figure out wait hold on a second
i gotta i gotta make sure we don't have
voter id you are saying what happened
how many how many just came in just now
while i turned around yeah three million
that's crazy wow the biggest a lot we
have to estimate it without going over
really
does anyone smell oh it was me
plinko
[Laughter]
i want that long microphone if you bit a
dollar i'll slug you
so millie if in case uh
there was still any doubt as to whether
he was completely incompetent he was
asked about bagram air base yeah which
of course is the air base that we had in
afghanistan which we abandoned to then
try and uh uh well look let's first have
him answer this is supposed to be one of
the most brilliant uh military minds of
our time folks did you at any point
create options for keeping bagram open
beyond july 2nd
i'm sorry i didn't catch the last part
if bagram had stayed open would our
support to the afghan air force have
been more
effective
in your view yes or no
uh frankly i'm not sure on that one
because most of the afghan air force was
a different basis specifically at hkia
okay well i'm not a joint chiefs of
staff here uh but i i i can do a little
bit of the banging
uh a little bit of the duck it's a
little difficult matter of fact just
that bent back paper clip and um word uh
from 98 would still be more i i have no
idea really you're a military strategist
you are to advise on military issues and
you have no idea if an air base in the
middle of nowhere surrounded by land
mines was an effective stronghold that
we should have kept in lieu of trying to
depart from crowded kandahar one of the
most crowded cities i think the most
crowded city in afghanistan that had
already been overtaken by the taliban
here's a picture side by side so you can
see your bagram air base surrounded by
landmines kandahar
hard to tell can't tell it's almost like
it would have been helpful to have that
second base who knows hey would it be
easier to secure area 51 or times square
i'll have to get back to you
the question was phrased in a way like
is is it easier to help their military
forces to help their air force and it's
like having the us presence anywhere
makes that easier yes the answer is
always yes it was a trick question sir
you missed it you should have just said
yes but we decided to do something
different and then he said we were all
surprised by the collapse of the afghan
forces well i don't know it seems like
you're surprised by the fact that having
an entirely protected military air base
is uh beneficial so it seems to me
you're just generally surprised tomato
tomato that should be his name general
surprise yes who are you huh the
question king oh
just a concerned american i have giant
baggy
fluffy eyes i look like i'm in the
frighteners
i'm a corpse uh
i like her hair he looks like when the
face and scream comes over the head
through the wall
uh what's that scream i don't know what
to do no the writer's right here
isn't there isn't that also freddy
oh
yeah no freddy sucks johnny dip into the
bed no that's one of the things comes
through the wall
one lucky freddy yes johnny depp was in
freddy's oh yeah he got killed very
quickly he got cast you know why
he's friends with nicholas cage they
went to an audition
uh wes craven's daughter was like i
think he's hot
he got hired nice to die a nigga's cage
like do you mean me yeah no and the
the guy you brought the other strange
actor oh johnny she finds you attractive
uh
the one in the friendships bracelets
and skull rings
as a billionaire he wears nine dollar
jewelry
chuggy cheese
i got eight friendship bracelets all
right
could you cut them off you're playing a
pirate hold that thought i have to get
my ass kicked by a woman yeah
um oh i know that's sad of course it is
i felt like johnny depp i don't love
johnny depp i love it i do he got the
short end of the stick there amber heard
his name oh he's a monster she's a
psycho well i like johnny depp well when
she used the tampon applicator to say he
was snorting cocaine it's like this is
clearly it was a stage picture yeah it
was that she took yeah a photo of him
was like yeah he's always just bottles
around this is what his breakfast is
coke out of a tampon application yes
speaking of uh speaking of of psycho
witches uh hey here's something that
happened on the view yesterday and then
we'll get to australia uh uh caitlyn
jenner uh spoke out saying that people
should have the right to make their own
choice as it relates to their body and
the vaccine and whoopi goldberg makes a
very uh uh cutting point i'm about
individual freedoms um
there's not a one size fits all
what about pregnant women what about
there's everybody has a challenge about
pregnant women and and i just feel like
that is a decision between a doctor
and and their patients personal choice
yeah once you know what you can listen
i'll tell you they're trying to get it
why that doesn't work because if we
waited for people to make the choice i
would not have the right to vote in this
country if we didn't if we didn't
[Applause]
by the way uh went on to a great
commercial for a ladies uh clothing
company o lineman r us
it has gotten a little bigger yeah so
let's be really clear which one oh
they're all hot beautiful and brave all
of them uh all of them let's be really
clear here this is what they usually
need to use this comparison to with the
same sex marriage thing the right it's a
really easy card to pull out uh
all right
choice vaccine saying yeah but but if we
had to leave it up to choice child it's
crazy my people wouldn't have the right
to vote okay in one instance we're
talking about recognizing right right i
don't want to say granting the
government recognizing more of our
god-given freedoms namely the god-given
freedom of bodily autonomy in the other
example you're talking about racist
southern democrats trying to remove
freedom
from black americans namely the right to
vote longest two filibusters in history
democrats right right to vote black
people so do you see the difference more
freedom less freedom i hope i've
distilled it for you i hope it's not too
reductive it's it's well it's actually
the same thing it's a right to choose
because people choose whether or not
they go and vote right it's point it's a
point the point is it was a freedom that
should have been recognized from the
get-go all men are created equal you
look at the founding fathers they had a
gross problem with slavery yeah but they
had slaves look a lot of them were born
into a community with slaves they freed
their slaves upon their death nobody is
perfect you have to judge them by that
point in history they got the ball
moving to end slit every nation at some
point has had slavery let's be clear
there are plenty of nations that still
have slavery i love the little switch
too that uh that our friends in the uk
pull they go well actually it was
outlawed in the uh it was actually
outlawed in england before the united
states not the british empire you were
still sustaining yourself you
colonialist pricks on slavery and we had
one of the most violent wars in history
took a while it was a matter of
recognizing the constitutional rights
meaning the freedoms of all americans
versus right now unconstitutionally
removing them this doesn't have to be
hard folks don't find yourself
flat-footed with this and i don't
understand why the audience is clapping
it's like are you really that dense that
you can't understand that those two
things have no relationship to each
other absolutely you're an audience
yes it's someone in a vaccine costume
with an applause that's true they kind
of just move studios but no i mean
caitlyn even says oh yeah that's a fair
point i'm like no it really is not a
fair point well she has here's what joy
said too in that same clip right i know
she has to but still
and that's the only reason whoopi said
like you can't come back
if we waited we wouldn't have the right
to vote joy said well what about
pregnant women my wife is pregnant joy
do you have a problem with pregnant
women wanting to make sure they don't
put something in their body in the first
trimester that could kill their child
potentially yeah i'm not saying it does
i'm saying that that's not the standard
of proof the standard of proof anyone
out there who's been pregnant women
who've been pregnant you can comment
below the standards
we have to make sure that there isn't if
there's any risk at all if we don't know
that we are guaranteed already studies
have been conducted that it will not
harm yeah the child then you don't take
it right women can't have a turkey
sandwich they can't have yellow they
can't have yellow fin tuna that's
exactly so let me clarify i am not
saying that the vaccine will kill your
child at all i am saying that you take
the precautionary measure against all
substances that might have an impact
until you know they won't including we
went to have sushi the other night and
she couldn't eat sushi at the very least
they should have the right to well yes
of course if you wanna if you wanna look
and we have no but if you wanna raise
third nipple grandkids that's your
prerogative
that's on you just don't make me do it
depends on where you have twins that'd
be six nipples just not on the forehead
that's that's a little bit too many naps
yeah
i don't like i love dogs they're my
favorites yeah but when one's got the
nipples hanging out you're like come
back when those aren't there yeah like
i'd like to pet you but a belly rub this
is a felony
dave you have male dogs
uh i have a male dog my female dog died
thanks for bringing that up it's been a
rough wow gerald thanks gerald i really
thought you were getting better about
the nipples dave do you feel good about
what you just did jail i do okay
he sent me a headstone of the dog
he was like i'm gonna bring this up on
the show
i said too soon shouldn't have fed her
chocolate sorry that's uh
this is our
climate uh day good week thing and we
have to go back with our climate
correspondent thomas finnegan on the
ground
[Music]
all right mr finnegan you there sir
stephen yep
as we could see that all this smoke is
not good for their environment we're
going to continue the experiment no
we're going to make sure that we have
the full effect no you don't need to
continue gentlemen make sure your ac's
are on full i want to hear some wind no
that doesn't that's and rev
and red i'm not a revving captain and
rev that's enough
that says thomas i don't thomas look
this isn't that the point was to be
actually reducing emissions
can he hear you is it a uh is that a
cinder block
oh this seems very bad
that's not safe no no
no
[Music]
uh okay well we'll uh check back in ill
advise
he smokes didn't this ducky tell him to
switch to non-filters
i think it was doctor told him to switch
to cools but uh that's right he's an
urban doctor oh he had to go there and
he has a steak he has a bias funniest
thing
yeah
zack i got a cough what do i do i'm
gonna prescribe you pack a coupon
let's see if we can end it faster wait
what are you saying doc what
what i'm saying is your eyes are smoking
mental huh
problem the correction
yeah i think my doctor would have
swagger i see you're smoking newport
it's going to give you a little
prescribe for some newport lights there
you go
and you get 100's that way you get the
same smokes just saying his head that's
all it is it's basically just a
cigarette dispenser yeah someone walks
in and secretary and she goes uh yes uh
this next gentleman smokes chest or
feels no
no no no no no no no yeah that's the
fields it's parliamentary doctor what is
your phd in tobacco tobacco
you work for big pharma
i do i work for the bureau of oh you
work for the bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms no i work for the bureau of
cool oh now here are some dancing
cigarettes
go smoke them all right let's uh look
let's talk about australia here um
this is uh this is this is something
that's been going on and
sometimes you need to learn from your
international brothers and there are a
lot of good people in australia this is
something i've been watching closely we
didn't want to hit it first because we
wanted to see if they rescinded some of
these laws we wanted to see if they
would improve some of these laws because
you don't want to dance on uh the graves
of the freedom
of anybody right but it's only gotten
worse and americans you need to
understand that this started long before
covet now i've always said do not comply
if you want to wear a mask you
absolutely should wear a mask if you
want to uh take a vaccine you want to
use that you absolutely should i have a
blind policy here i don't need to know
what anyone does
with their own bodies as it relates to
the vaccine we don't even drug test here
because i know some people would fail
and i don't need to know hey what
they're doing as long as they're
productive i am very less a faculty okay
however in austria in australia uh they
have reached uh terrifying levels of
tyranny let me let me let me put a finer
point in it it is absolutely a
tyrannical hell hole when people say oh
you're just fear-mongering i think what
is going on in australia right now is
enough and there was a slow march toward
this so for people who don't know
in australia right now and we've been
updating this to the minute as we can
this is what happens to the citizens of
an allegedly free country if you dare go
against the covid lockdown policies
[Applause]
[Music]
that lady by the way her mask was uh not
on was below her face
she was exempt
that one she was yeah oh did a medical
exam well no what like like what like
she has a an air issue breathing issue
nah that suspended during
a pandemic
no no no never
this is truly horrifying yeah this this
absolutely is horrifying and we had to
select
look there's tons of these videos yeah
go to uh we have all the references
available at lightweight.com the link is
in the description there's more footage
than you could watch in a lifetime now
let me be really clear i'm going to go
through some of the lockdown measures
that have been issued
uh and then the history of what's been
going on in australia rights that are
not recognized oh hold on a second
really quickly youtube cracking down on
vaccine misinformation yeah cnn by the
way no conflict of interest here just
when you have brian stelter on sundays
he has a rotating chiron that just says
youtube facebook twitter he's just
giving them free plugs to try and bow to
the king let's see what he's talking
about here this man with the uh
the vaccine eric disinformation that
youtube has been slow to react to i mean
it's not the first time we've said huh
weren't you doing this already why not
that's right i mean on this very show
just a few weeks before last year's
election i should award a tie youtube
ceo told poppy that she wasn't sure if
youtube was going to ban cuanon
um
take the most extreme example to make a
point
how about the doctors who've been
removed from youtube yeah how about the
doctors who've seen thousands of
patients
well how about
you announce still has freedom of speech
that's a good point as well that's a
very good point as well even i'm that's
a good point but they are taking the
most extreme example to make of course
so people watching cnn don't realize
doctors have been removed scientists
have been roofed they don't realize
certain videos in the world health
organization well we got removed because
you were quoting medical stats and
talking about your wife as a nurse and
what the common practices are in the
hospital true so
it's my fault yeah but no and a few
minutes ago perfect example i wanted to
make sure i clarified because i don't
want the youtube overlords to come in
and say oh well they said these vaccines
are going to do things no i did not say
that that's why i had to clarify no
we've never said not what i'm saying we
have never said anything that's the
world they're creating the most
controversial thing we've ever said on
this show is that covet is significantly
more lethal than the flu to old people
but younger people's immune system react
differently and that is interesting to
study as we move forward with the
science that you are at significantly
greater risk than the standard flu if
you are immune compromised or if you are
old but the stats are different across
age groups that's what we have said and
i won't even get to the specifics
because we got in trouble we got into
trouble because we specifically quoted
the cdc and they said well you know
people may not take it seriously if you
say that so yeah all right guess what
don't care that's what we're talking
about now and this guy right there you
don't need to be in a basement with a
red with a red yarn
a serial killer to to make the
connections look
i was at fox news for four and a half
years okay i'm going to let you in on a
little inside baseball
my clips where i was on f were removed
why because back then fox said well
youtube we don't want things on youtube
the same thing with cnn appeared on cnn
up here tonight i've appeared on bbc
appeared on sky news hated every minute
of it
yes you did uh ctv two in canada radio
canada this is i did this for a long
time before i said you know what all my
energy is going to go into this show
this is the only thing that matters
because it's it really is
it's a shell game okay this this game is
rigged with media however now cnn
colbert
all of these networks they want to be on
youtube we're going to have a segment
yeah upcoming in the future about auto
play where you want to play independent
content and then you get seth meyers
their advertising is based on youtube
hits a lot of the time exactly so they
want to
now increase their share of the market
on youtube cnn they're late to the party
when it comes to content they get beaten
by the competition by places like yours
truly tim poole a lot of independent
content creators so they want to
eliminate competition and they just
happen to have the hundreds of millions
of dollars to spend with youtube with
facebook with twitter for advertising to
make sure that their stuff gets featured
first really misinformation
miss it how about russiagate
does that get taken everything okay are
the videos still up where fouch said
don't wear a mask where fauci said that
americans should be more concerned with
the standard flu i get it you're saying
time changes times change sure but back
then there were plenty of scientists
there were plenty of experts who were
disagreeing with fauci
then to be clear it's not that someone
changes their opinion it's do they
change their opinion in light of new
information for example fauci said that
kids could catch aids from a cereal box
if their parents had it in the house he
said this for years and at that point
the world's leading scientists who
didn't get the chance to be in front of
every camera that they've ever seen
right every single time they see a it's
like it's like it's like those uh those
fly traps to felt you just that red
light in the camera just
it's all he cares about there were
scientists back then you said no no no
no you can't get him a cereal box uh
really well how are you saying you get
aids uh gay anal sex or dirty needles
it's preposterous he knew it then yeah
only now everyone else was banned at
that time and now when fauci changes
opinion how do we know that he's right
yeah well it's not just doctors the most
egregious case was ron desantis the
governor of a great gigantic state yeah
was having a conversation with doctors
some would say that that's something
that the public needs to be able to see
yeah and the doctors were from quack
institutes like harvard and i believe
oxford and stanford right
oh my gosh you're going to take that off
and you're going to say that this is
misinformation because the governor's
having a conversation hey you know what
else is really scary you saw last night
i got another one of those complaints
from uh for german law violating german
law keep breaking german
took the flag down in front of your
house yeah i have no idea what i did i
don't know maybe i mentioned the fact
that they acted up a couple times in the
last century
i'm not happy about that but when i get
it
i get it all the time you violated
german law you violated pakistan but
these are international corporations who
pl look at what happened with china in
the hong kong protest look at the
throttling that happened just yesterday
f joe biden was trending
throttled f donald trump went up the
counter trend which is smaller than a
real trend what do you think happens
when they have this power and they want
to play ball with the australian
government who do you think is looking
out for it's why i'm no longer a
libertarian go start your own youtube go
start your own facebook go start your
own twitter you can't do that now
especially when they benefit from
monumental government bills that favor
them as public platforms even though
they act like private publishers and cnn
wants it cnn wants this show gone cnn
wants all of your voices gone they can't
stand it and that's just why look i'm
self plugged here uh consider joining my
club dot com club additional hour of
show every day also you know how much we
made in youtube
zero is it but did you round up or yeah
yeah okay i think germany i had show
around flagging people yes oh they're
poop porn
okay so we'll go back to australia we
just saw those videos of the protest
sorry i just got all wrapped up about
this um yesterday the victoria
department of health um
uh their their minister martin foley
here's something that's interesting to
me he announced that 78
of the current coveted hospitalizations
were vaccinated okay that up that's uh
oh we have a clip clip yeah there we go
we also have
375 you should wear a tie
with covered it's high sodium michael
caine 81 of those are in intensive care
and 61 are on a ventilator
of the people who were in hospital
yesterday
78
were vaccinated and 17 were partially
vaccinated and that number is what do
you say high sodium michael k yeah
what do you think i can't wear a tie
anymore it's because it makes my head
look like a balloon
they call me michael candy cane i've
been eating a lot they call me michael
candy cane
it's my fridge so
78 of current hospitalizations right are
vaccinated you just saw that for
yourself yes sir currently
only 50 of the country is vaccinated now
this matters because the numbers that
they have been trying to manipulate and
i've i've granted them this right the
argument because the argument holds
water when you say look black americans
make up 12 of the population yeah but a
significantly higher percentage of the
prison population they are
disproportionately represented you have
liberals who make that argument that
they these laws target black americans
and minorities more right okay this is
an argument that's made and it's one
that we've always acknowledged hold some
water if you're using the law of
percentages they've tried to use that
here with the vaccine where they say
well the only reason that 90 something
percent in israel in the hospitals uh
are vaccinated is because the majority
of the population is vaccinated first
off that wouldn't hold water if it was a
vaccine that you know like all other
vaccines immunized you that being said
right now 78
of the hospitals vaccinated in australia
50 percent of the that means that there
is a higher percentage of people
vaccinated in the hospitals than the
general population now i understand that
correlation does not equal causation i
took humanities 101 and college 2.
however
this means that if you were to conduct a
clinical trial using the same standard
of the science
this would at the very least
not past phase one because it's no more
effective than placebo in this instance
significantly less effective than
placebo 78 of hospitalizations
vaccinated only 50 percent of the hosp
of the population meaning you if you did
nothing you would be better off with a
50 50 shot if this were to be a clinical
study
that matters because the argument can no
longer be used well it's just a
reflective of the population well and i
i read through that and i thought oh man
70. that's that's a pretty compelling
case it got worse i don't know if you
heard what he said right after that 17
of people had one dose
that means if i'm hearing that correctly
that means five to six percent of the
people in hospital right now are
unvaccinated i want to make sure that we
have that right if 78 percent includes a
total of one right or whatever you're
saying or if they're saying that's fully
vaccinated and then an additional 17
percent only have one let me see what do
we have 7.3 did he say 17 people no he
said 17 in the clip he said i like the
little nickelodeon he says
one dose or two yeah so 17 of it so 50
is one dose no no i'm saying what he
said is 78 of the people in the hospital
are vaccinated right then he said an
additional 17 percent have at least did
you say additional that's that's what i
thought i heard him say so if i could
play again let's play the clip again
i want to make sure because i was
reading this this morning and you may
have caught something i missed we also
have
375 people
with covert in hospital at the moment 81
of those are in intensive care and 61
are on a ventilator
of the people who were in hospital
yesterday
78
were vaccinated and 17 were partially
vaccinated so yeah i don't know if he's
saying an additional it almost sounds
like he's saying an additional because
why would he break down the 78 he'd say
of those 17 percent had one the point is
it doesn't matter well i mean it's worse
sorry it looks like it's worse it's
significantly worse he looks like the
colonel after uh dirk jiggler exposes
himself at the pool party doesn't he
when he's like may i see it and then
afterwards his glasses are
sideways boogie knocks that film was
crude so
keep in mind that they are saying they
will be maintaining the covert
restrictions until 80 percent of the
population is vaccinated wow so you need
to meet an 80 percent threshold which by
the way is change remember it was vouchy
they said they said 80. then biden said
97.98 the point is the goal posts will
always be moved they never give up this
power let me read you some of these
restrictions just so you know i'm not
making it up again the sources are
available link in the description uh
only one in sydney specifically
which is where the majority of the
footages come from only one person can
leave the house to get food per day uh
going to shops browsing is not allowed
you have to register for travel leaving
sydney you have to work from home it's
mandatory whenever possible mandatory
face masks um your
there's a five person limit on any
outdoor activities for vaccinated people
um
you can't have visitors at home unless
for specific reasons like child care or
an emergency if you live alone you're
permitted one nominated visitor who can
visit you in your home choose well you
can't share cars with people you don't
live with except for specific reasons
like an emergency even if it's a subaru
outback
uh blue and onions can only be sure
while wearing latex gloves you have to
carry proof of name and address if you
have left your home and present it to
the police unless of course you're going
to vote
must have proof of vaccination and show
it to police
mandatory check-ins qr codes anyone this
is something that happened in canada too
by the way
um
oh by the way all kangaroos have to wear
masks when boxing this is something that
happened in canada when you went back to
canada you had to uh self quarantine at
your own dime
the same thing in australia you have to
spend the average cost anywhere from
three to five thousand dollars in
mandated hotel quarantine wow and that's
of course stranded now who does this
affect this affects the most wealthy
among uh this affects the the most poor
among us yeah the wealthy can afford to
travel and visit a dying relative the
wealthy can afford right to somehow flop
these lockdown laws the wealthy can
afford that the poor in the country the
middle class can't afford three to five
thousand dollars to self quarantine and
so what happens you zoom your dying life
what happens you maybe don't get to go
see the birth of your child this is the
kind of stuff that happens you've been
seeing it across the country of course
the wealthy the elites are not affected
in the same way they're too busy eating
at the french laundry um
all right we're getting a blowout and
here's something else speaking of uh
when you're not doing hotels they've
been building and this is something too
look frog in the boiling water and i get
alex jones on the show he says some
crazy stuff but now you really was not
that crazy look look look
i have seen where they are building the
fema camps we're like oh alex you're so
crazy okay well they have
government-built mandated quarantine
buildings in australia to them it
wouldn't you'd say look government
government buildings for fema camps they
say yeah
problem because here's what's going on
howard springs near darwin is held up as
the gold standard of quarantine separate
cabins
on-site testing gold standard of
trailers
and so far no known breaches this is a
commitment
it's the nicest concentration camp you
ever seen yeah the side of the people
this one's going to be done in 2024
and the biggest sorry what yeah tell me
they're planning on just being a short
pendant
out of queensland is to build as quickly
as possible a regional crew he's getting
the contract on that it's not a
concentration in the airport
you get out and they shoot the pilot
i think i see ricky in bubbles
just waiting patiently to be fed it's
like when you shake the uh the bag of
dog the dog treats and dogs come running
we're all just outside waiting
oh my gosh disturbing man
i
what the all right that really really
really should bother everybody who's
seeing that if you're if you're looking
at australia right now the list of
things that you just went down the
government has no right to tell me when
i can and cannot leave my house and by
the way they don't have a right to ping
me and say hey make sure in the next 15
take a picture you have to take a
picture that shows us that you're at
your house they actually do in countries
that's what i'm saying
i know i'm that's what i'm saying like
in general we don't believe that the
government exists for that reason
they're there to acknowledge those
rights that is true period yeah that is
not just an idea that we had this was
something that was self-evident that's
why we said it that way right the the
government deciding when and what you
can eat is terrifying yeah i will put
you in a camp oh really that's never
going to be used and it never has in
history before right he's in the camp
that's breadlines that's there's so many
you know variations of that that is hey
it's just egregious we're all in this
together this is just look things will
go back to normal the k but think that
every camp's not going to be done until
2024. don't look to me tomato tomato
potato potato it's a knife that's not at
all helpful 2024 which by the way could
probably get trump on it could probably
have that go up
within six months yeah come on people
weren't dealing with audits and
impeachment what are they gonna do like
you we're supposed to flatten the curb
not plan ahead for concentration yes
well we need to build just giant trailer
parks where we throw them in like a zoo
you can't pet anything though i know and
i understand that it's a penal colony
filled with murderers and rapists so
well no one should be surprised however
yeah they should be fighting harder
against those guys
i expected more you guys came from the
worst listen here you tell me i can't
leave my house
my father was a rapist more grinded was
a rapist and his dead fears did was a
rapist you understand where i'm going
with this
yeah if you want me to stay home you're
going to be in here with me yes exactly
light some candles rose battles but i
won't call you back
so australia by the way has actually
deployed the military in helicopters to
tell people to go home and comply with
so when you say military state i don't
know maybe it looks something like this
[Music]
well thank god you're not in afghanistan
that would be a biting drone killing 10
people including seven children i see
some people dropping the point that you
just made i talked about this with
jordan peterson yeah um south australia
this is they made their citizens write
quarantine download an app yep yeah
and uh
randomly request that they send a photo
of themselves in their quarantine
location within 15 minutes of the
request otherwise they send in the
authorities first of all i'll send dick
pics yeah that's actually across the
board come on
that would be amazing come over here
she's supposed to be in quarantine but i
can't see i can't see the location but i
can't find a location penis just here's
nothing but dicks
look at that it's just [ __ ] balls
please what is that i can't tell look i
can't make out that's not a
topographical map i do know that he's
next to a diet coke yes people of
australia i beseech you yes let's do
this make this happen yeah you want to
win this is how you do this this is how
you win you look at my boomerang you
subvert the technology he's an
aboriginal dick that's not a joke
this is a dick
i tell you there's a loyal dick through
it comes right back
they have to investigate it they're like
this isn't even the same color penis you
sent the left side i don't know if it's
the same guy
oh please make this happen i want this
so bad you want to tell me that's not
scarier than the virus with a two
percent hospitalization rate which
includes by the way 80 and 90 year olds
you want to tell me the government being
able to tell you to send them a picture
within 15 minutes or they send men with
guns
is not scarier than the virus at what
point do we say that the cure is worse
than the disease i think it's a fair
question to ask how far does it have to
go here for you to not comply with
anything you know what with my i would
tell my daughter don't ever send a
picture to a guy you don't know with
your location never but yeah that's true
right i don't know and if you we we've
talked about the police before and i
know we're going to talk about in a
minute but we played videos that are
just absolutely scary it's not like they
come and like say hey you have to put a
mask on you have to do this people were
actually protesting just because they
didn't think that the lockdowns were
good and they were already pinned on the
ground in that same video we saw
somebody was kneed in the back by a
second officer the other guy that was
already on the ground pinned down was
kicked in the head
every day in the united states people
would be in the streets raiding and
burning
but listen
this is australia
i'll kick to the back of the head more
dead kick to the back of the head he's
dead kick his dead's dead kick to the
back of him my point is if someone
breaks the lockdown rules someone's
getting the back of the head kicked
that's what all the prisoners are now
the cops yeah exactly well that's true
and all these restrictions have of
course led to compare this to uh here in
the united states you know for example
like let's say january 6 which is the
most horrible event that's ever occurred
in modern american history of course um
sure yeah the protests the backlash and
just look at the backlash i sound like
the teenager in the symptoms the
simpsons the fat guy wants to see the
movie so um look at the backlash here
these people
charge the cops
so you need to understand the context
for these people in australia who've
submitted to these authorities for a
very long time um
these have led to massive protests as in
in some cases some
they absolutely should
[Applause]
oh
wow look at that they're just running
right through
you've never seen that in the united
states is one of them rip taylor
oh i guess not
this is insane
[Applause]
and you know the only reason that those
people aren't being roughed up by the
cops is they can't rough up all of them
[Music]
let that be a lesson folks
well they're right there i mean
it's nothing against the cops are doing
their job but these people are
absolutely right
i cannot arrest all of us
freedom
and they cannot arrest me for stealing
my friend dan's horse
[Laughter]
i know he's going to rape me later but
worth it
was a horse
if there's a horse around i'm getting it
listen son you may not like it it's all
thievery that feeds you and clothes you
where do you sell them to people who
want to buy cheaper horses yes
do you hope the fans brought the rubber
gloves yeah did you see so in that first
video where they broke through and i'm
not advocating for violence but there
was some guy like neo in the matrix it
was like elbow just one guy punched this
guy running through kick to that guy i
swear oh yeah it was like a movie he
watched the speech from braveheart
before he went out that day he was
really pumped i'm not kidding it was
like one step to another was like big
pow boom like he was hitting people i
was like oh my gosh it was this guy came
prepared yeah exactly there's a little
uh um and look this is so this is going
on right now however
this is why we've done changed my mind
here at the shows you need to recognize
what's happening before it gets this far
there have been a lot of warning signs
when i was watching those protests and
the cops pelting them which by the way
in the united states some of these
videos are using what look like actual
rifle carbines i don't know that they
use those with paintballs i haven't seen
it so that's concerning because you
can't tell what's real versus what's
important around that so anyways
an aside we'll maybe go back to that um
i thought well thank god that these
people who are being locked in their
houses and having their wives roughed up
for going for a jog thank god these
people don't have any guns or things
could get out of control oh so it's
almost like that was a plan yeah it's
almost like that none of this would be
happening it's almost like we always
told you hey don't do that but you
didn't yeah so there was there was and
this is something that beethoven
supports say hell yeah we'll do the
united states in australia i can give
the ins and outs really simple there's a
gun ban there's a gun ban yeah he called
it a buyback and people here try and
sell you on this idea of a gun buyback
it was a mandatory buyback what does
that mean you sell your you sell your
gun to the government turn it in or they
send guys with guns to take them away
from you that's what happened in 96 in
australia by the way
people didn't really have an effect on
gun crime let's be very clear people
will argue back and forth
let's say it did it doesn't matter the
disease is not as bad as the cure at
this point something else they have a
surveillance bill and we have that here
in the united states patriot act
understand have some problems with it
yeah this uh surveillance bill in 2020
allowed australia to um
uh spy on and take the accounts of
potential cyber criminals here's the
thing though
they don't need to investigate or charge
people with a crime to use it at all
that's incredible and of course
something else that is uh pretty
important to me this is how it starts
you wonder how do they crack down on
protesters how do they beat someone up
for protesting well guess what australia
doesn't have free speech
i've talked about this one of the first
changed my minds that i did was a
sandwich board because we couldn't get a
perm a permit yeah it was a permit we
couldn't get a porpoise they're
expensive how are you gonna bring it on
land
has to be uh
just get to some good old poopish
thieving
oh my god so the australian constitution
does not list a right to free speech
let's be really clear this is the
difference between common law versus
what we have here in the united states
okay and this is why i did a hate speech
is not real changed my mind that's
important to know hate speech is not a
thing
here in the united states in other
countries it's a loosely defined term
that can be used to subject its citizens
so we have no more firearms we have no
more privacy you notice i almost fell
down yeah i saw that idiotic we have no
more [ __ ] with no death perception
so they have no firearms to protect
themselves yeah they have no privacy
right this is because you don't have a
god-given right to privacy it's the
government the government grants you
rights and they don't have a right to
speak out publicly yeah let's be really
clear hate speech is illegal in
australia under section 18 c of the
racial discrimination act that's how
they shoehorn it in makes it unlawful
for someone to do an act that is
reasonably likely to offend insult
humiliate or intimidate someone because
of
race or ethnicity who gets to determine
what is a reason something that is
reasonably likely to defend according to
who right you just made it so subjective
that you can pretty much use it however
you want which i think was the goal well
that's also the issue because here in
the united states some of you think well
these people are crazy and at least it's
just professors and in hollywood
checking white privilege and how
everything is white supremacy but
honestly everyone most people know that
that's bullcrap the issue is the
government says it's not in australia so
racism now isn't the actual belief that
someone of a different race is inferior
to you which is horrible ungodly and
immoral and i find disgusting however
people have the right
to personally be racist here in the
united states it's terrible yeah but
people of all races do it's awful
we try to fight it
through ideas we actually fought it
through one of the bloodiest wars of all
time and legislation however people have
the right to say things certainly that
could be determined to be offensive by
the government who by the way may
believe in critical race theory who by
the way may say that all white people
need to check their privilege and if you
don't oh you might be racist and of
course it's been used against the
citizens because it's a sliding scale
and whoever is in power will abuse it
yeah so basically what you just told me
let me just recap the australia thing
you have no way of defending yourself
right you have no authority to tell
people that they can't come into your
house from the government and force you
to do whatever they tell you to do
because you have no right to privacy and
then you can't speak out about it when
it happens to warn other citizens so
that they can understand what's going on
that's exactly is that is that i just
want to make sure i have that clear that
that sounds like every bad movie we have
seen where there's a dictator in power
that has to be overthrown that's exactly
what you would think but the good news
is right now it's only temporary just
check the trailer parks that will be
until 2024. well they had nice sidewalks
yeah it's like you could take a walk on
them you know go for a stroll and oh but
i'll be out front waiting for my gruel
please ask some more groups
of men selling aluminum siding or making
an absolutely yeah and these laws these
other laws i'm about to go through here
may seem insignificant but again they
all add up because these laws are
permissible only because your rights are
not unalienable they're not god-given
it's granted to you by the government so
they can
take it away you thought you did that
right don't have that right it's my
right everyone everyone who wears right
step forward or you not so fast
my grandpappy didn't have royce
i don't have rights and he's dead he's
dead he well he was eaten by a shack
that was very hard for all of us
they're out there
so uh here are some small infringements
on your feet you can't well you can't
buy alcohol after 10 p.m that doesn't
seem like a big one oh son of a you need
a permit for outdoor picnics that can
piss people off you have a 300 fine for
not wearing a bike helmet or as john
oliver would uh call it common sense
you have uh a law proposed to charge
twenty two hundred dollars for too much
smoke from a barbecue i don't think
that's actually a lawyer come on your
honor i would have brought you smoking
the barbecue they took my last three
hundred dollars yes and uh of course
they uh they want it's illegal to wear
body armor that's something that i don't
understand it's a defensive tool yeah
well how about that
body armor because you might uh
you might hit someone with it i don't
know i might use my gun with it that's
what i might use this is to protect me
the argument is that well you might be
able to defend yourself and
well the other thing is already illegal
so the the whole idea is that you're
gonna be like the la robbers that were
out there shooting at police officers
and they couldn't be hit it's like
they're already doing something illegal
you don't need to make the body armor
illegal right going and shooting at
police officers illegal problem solved
yeah how amazing was that they just
dressed like the the dart or the black
knight from uh oh it was monty python
and the holy grail it was just like an
iceberg and just body armor i understand
why that could be a problem however you
don't remove the rights no you should
totally be able to wear body armor
everywhere you go yeah i'm serious and
people shouldn't even know just for fun
yeah it's funny why are you dressed like
that and you're like what if something
goes down yeah i'm in body armor also
are you stronger it's like weighted
clothing like yeah dragon ball z yeah
what's your problem piccolo the point
here is yeah
look you want to seem silly you may want
to think that this cannot happen here in
the united states it shouldn't be able
to because the constitution but since
we've seen that that has been used
effectively as continental wipes over
the last year and people have said you
have the president who said i don't
think it's constitutional but we're
gonna do it anyways specifically with
the rent moratorium he said i don't
think it's constitutional but uh we're
gonna do it anyways we'll say the cdc
has control over the population and rent
uh during uh
health uh pandemic measures something or
other probably won't hold up but it'll
take six months to get to the court you
have someone who has said the quiet part
out loud that he doesn't care in the
constitutionality of it well then if he
says i don't care about that
constitutionality
right the uh the appropriate separation
of powers was to stop him from saying i
don't care about the constitutionality
of infringing on freedom of speech i
don't care about the constitutionality
of taking your guns away or as beto
o'rourke has said hell yeah we'll do it
and then kickflips into oblivion
this is something that absolutely should
not happen in the united states but
absolutely can and it needs you need to
have your head on a swivel before a
pandemic love you need to be aware of
this this is why when people say oh you
know i'm just not really into politics
uh boring until it steps up to until
it's right at your front door right at
your front stoop guess what there have
been years of this going on and i've had
many many people a doctor right we have
a doctor friend who's lovely but he's
like i didn't think about this until my
daughter went to college yeah and guess
what we've been talking about this for
years before your collar your daughter
went to college there are a lot of of of
moms out there who this is a big problem
too with a lot of women because politics
are ugly yeah and if you look at the
polls you look at women are less engaged
in politics statistically than men for
the same reason like in a lot of sports
they have different interests but this
will directly affect you and your family
everyone needs to be engaged all the
time you don't have to be engaged 24 7
you need to unplug but guess what i bet
you there were a lot of australians who
said oh gun bad back not that big a deal
oh free speech law not that big a deal
and now the pandemic comes and they say
what the hell is happening that's what's
happening to a lot of americans right
now that's why you're seeing the polls
change that's why you're seeing the
trust and joe biden take a nosedive
people going whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa how did we get here i'll tell
you how we got here you weren't paying
attention australia wasn't paying
attention and they don't have the kind
of constitution that we have in america
people have not been paying attention
and you now have leaders who have
expressed clearly and vocally we don't
want to have the constitution that we
have that's where we are
don't become complacent and just comply
to be nice and this isn't the hill i
want to die in look there are more hills
to die on than not at this point
pandemic or no
i want to be very clear about that all
right we do have to get going uh but
before we we leave to mug club we'll be
taking your chat i actually ugh okay
well because we have them on retainer
uh our environmental correspondent
thomas finnegan one last time with
climate week
[Music]
okay thanks steven yeah it was uh oh
mostly successful experiment however no
i wouldn't say that the brick didn't
work out quite so well we told you to
bring a brick but we're trying to do our
part and i'll do mine
i i'm still confused mr finnegan as to
what what part
that no that's going to be some cfc's
[Music]
hey on the way out just to let you guys
know there was huge legislation of
course here in america uh regarding the
ozone layer we had to learn about that
as kids the largest hole in the ozone
layer is closed so i found that out this
week because i wasn't paying attention
but uh so
we're making progress right all right
mud club members will be taking your
chat and playing newest gender pronouns
youtube well uh just because of what uh
you guys did there on cnn and the guy
without a tie you need to piss off